thank you very much and good the good
evening members questioners officers of
the council and members of the public
watching live i welcome you to this
question and answer session
as of course you all know our regular
full council meeting was cancelled for
covert reasons nevertheless we have our
question and answer session tonight
especially in order to assure democratic
process
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking to please mute your
microphone this minimizes background
noise and will help everyone in
listening to the proceedings the number
of people who have submitted a question
have asked their question be read out by
a council officer on their behalf
all those who submitted a question
however we'll receive a written response
anyway
so opening straight on to question
number one regarding government funding
in margate from mrs johnston
please can i ask mr clapson from
democratic services to read out the
question on mrs
mrs johnson's behalf
thank you chair so the question is there
have been numerous public reports of
government funding for margate
throughout 2020 to date
could the leader please confirm how much
of that funding has gone to consultants
and how much has been received and given
to projects
meetings of all meet minutes of all
meetings where tdc is the accountable
body would be appreciated
thank you
thank you mr cleveson i call upon
councillor pugh to respond
thank you chair
the margate town deal is the only
funding program specifically
specifically for margate the council is
the accountable body for this program
and there is a significant amount of
information available on the margate
town deal web pages
www.margatetowndeal.co.uk
this includes minutes of meetings the
decision-making process how the town
investment plan was developed amongst
other information
the council was originally allocated 162
thousand and 19 pounds
capacity funding this was to set up the
town deal board and facilitate the
development of a town investment plan
including engaging sp uh engaging
specialist consultancy services
the council then bid for further
capacity funding and received seventy
thousand pounds
the capacity funding is aimed at the
development of the strategic plan and to
support the development of business
cases
so far 143
291 pounds of funding has been used to
support this work with a further 48 000
pounds being commissioned
this is to ensure that the council town
deal board and project sponsors and
delivery partners have the specialist
advice and expertise required to deliver
information needed from the ministry of
housing communities and local government
the capacity funding was not to deliver
projects
the allocation of up to 22.2 million is
for the final development and delivery
of projects
this capital funding will be allocated
once the business cases have been
completed and summary documents sent to
central government for sign off
margate was allocated 750 000
pounds as a town do area for a town
centre capital project the council is
about to let a contract for works on
51-57 high street market
the works include the replacement of the
roof ensuring the building is watertight
protecting it from further deterioration
and the strip out of the internal
materials and fittings that will enable
access to the asbestos containing
materials that require removal
the council also received funding for
reopening high streets safely to the
value of 126
456 pounds
this was spent across six areas in fact
not just margate on specific activities
thank you very much indeed councillor
pugh
question number two regarding the
garland pavilion from miss edwards
please can i call upon mr clapson again
to read out the question on miss
edward's behalf
mr clapson
thank you chad so this one is garland
residents association would like to have
a meeting to discuss the garland
pavilion which is on the asset list
they have contacted the council with no
replies or answers about making this
into a community center to bring all
garland residents together and have a
community space which we can use and be
proud of thank you
thank you mr clapton i call again on
council queue to respond council pew
thank you chair
the garnish pavilion on capstone road is
a small sports pavilion comprising of
eight changing cubicles toilets showers
and a referee's office
there would not be sufficient space for
community centre
this property also requires a further
work of research into its occupancy
before it would be ready and suitable
for viewings or transfer
however once this work has taken place
we can get back in touch with ward
councillors and community groups
thank you again
councillor pugh uh
moving then on to question number three
regarding an environmental forum from
miss pardo
please can i again ask mr clapton to
read that question on miss pardo's
behalf mr clapton thank you
so following the last ipcc report it has
become even clearer that climate change
is a threat we must tackle now
there are many environmental groups
currently working in planet i.e fanet xr
vanet friends of the earth rise up clean
up among others
would it be possible to create an
environmental forum in which all groups
of the council can work together on
future environmental changes ideas to
tackle future threats educational
resources etc thank you
thank you mr clapson i call upon council
cop to respond councillor cobb
thank you chair and thank you uh for
this question this administration takes
climate change seriously and we
recognize that there are groups in the
community working on environmental
issues that have a wealth of knowledge
and skills
we want to work more closely with them
in the future
an environmental forum is an excellent
idea and is something that tdc aspires
to however at present we do not have the
resources to start run and manage a full
forum instead we hope to invite a couple
of members from each environmental group
to an initial meeting in order to start
a discussion and share knowledge and
ideas we hope to do this before
christmas
in the meantime we have a number of
officers whose role is to work with the
community a biodiversity and
horticulture officer litter education
officer
coastal birds officer and athenic coast
projects officer all of these are on
hand to advise community groups in
environmental action we have also
employed a home energy officer who can
assist with reducing home energy costs
and emissions for educational resources
please see our website pages where you
can find information on what climate
change is and what you can do to help
we are currently drawing up strategies
with the associated action plans to
tackle climate change and although we
are in an emergency these take time and
if they are to be meaningful and
successful
we are particularly concentrating on our
greenhouse gas emissions our electricity
gas petrol and diesel use
use and would ask groups to also make
plans to reduce these emissions as only
then will we be able to achieve net zero
and keep temperature rise below 2
degrees celsius
we are also taking practical action as
quickly as possible such as changing to
renewable electricity contracts when
they come up for renewal and changing
the roots of our vehicles to reduce
diesel use there are many other actions
described on our web pages so i would
encourage everyone to look them up by
typing climate change into the tdc
website search bar and clicking on the
first option energy and climate change
we hope that the strategies and action
plans have been produced next summer
we will have the resources to work even
more closely with community groups on
climate change as only by working
together will we be able to reach net
zero and combat the ecological crisis
thank you very much indeed councillor
cub
i now have uh question number four
regarding southern water and future
housing developments from mrs mccourt uh
mrs mccourt will be reading her question
and i'm pleased to welcome her to the
meeting
please turn on your microphone and read
out the wording of the question that you
have submitted to the council
mrs mccourt
thank you
southern water has a history of showing
an utter disregard for the protection of
our marine environments for which tdc
has the responsibility to protect
as the local plan develops
regular discharges of untreated
southern water can't cope with managing
our wastewater safely now and will fare
no better once the proposed 17 000 homes
are built
what exactly does tdc propose to do to
ensure
no further damage is caused as a result
of sewage discharges by southern water
into our marine protected areas
and uphold their responsibility in
protecting our marine life as written in
our local plan
thank you very much indeed mrs mccourt a
concern for all of us
i call upon the leader to respond that's
flashback
thank you chair and thank you mrs mccall
for your question um water companies
including southern water are required to
comply with statutes such as the water
framework directive and bathing water
directive
the environment agency is the regulated
agency for the purposes of these
regulations this is not a function for
tdc as a local authority
the local plan refers to the high level
strategy for dealing with foul and
surface water from new developments
actions regarding this
for example the use of sustainable
drainage solutions for surface water
will be dealt with
through the planning process for
developments
i can also assure you that i am in
regular contact with the chief executive
of southern water and this council takes
this matter very seriously
and we are constantly
referring to
the southern water as to
new um studies that they are doing so i
can assure residents that we are
doing everything um that we can to keep
a close eye on the situation thank you
thank you very much indeed ashby
moving on again question number five
regarding the local plan from mr scott
please can i ask again mr clapton to
read out the question on behalf of mr
scott mr clapson
thank you jeff
what does councillor ashley say to those
in rural areas that will be negatively
affected by the local plan and to those
who include poverty after all after all
the local plan will be destroying land
that produces over 10 million loaves of
bread
thank you mr clapson back to your leader
council ashby
thank you chair and thank you for the
question
the local plan is prepared in accordance
with the government guide governance
guide guidance
that guidance in the national planning
policy framework does not provide
blanket protection for agricultural land
it only states that where significant
development of agricultural land is
necessary areas of poor quality land
should be preferred to those of higher
quality
this has to be balanced against the
important objective of meeting future
housing needs and other government
guidance
it would be more appropriate to direct
this question to the national government
as a national food strategy covering
food security and food poverty
could be given additional weight in the
planning system if changes were made to
the national planning policy framework
to provide greater protection for
agricultural land
for myself personally as leader of the
council
i am writing to the secretary of state
to ask whether or not they will consider
having another close look at the
agricultural policy so i can assure you
that from authentic perspective we are
trying to deal with this on a national
strategy level this is a national
strategy issue
so i hope that you can also
write to the secretary of state yourself
with your concerns thank you
thank you very much councillor ashby
question number six regarding the
council's relationship with gladman
development limited uh from mr woodward
again uh can i please ask mr clapson to
read out the question on mr woodward's
behalf
mr clapson thank you chair
could the council please explain its
perpetual invasiveness and lack of
transparency towards questions asked
about all aspects of its relationship
with gladman developments limited
especially when applications from them
are both highly emotive and contentious
for the residents of planet thank you
thank you again mr clapton i call again
on the leader councillor ashby to
respond councillor ashby
thank you chair and thank you for the
question
we have received a number of requests
under the freedom of information about
this site we have received some
questions about meetings between gladman
and the council and other questions that
have been about other issues to do with
this application
the council has answered these requests
as openly as possible bearing in mind
that pre-application discussions between
the applicant and the council are
confidential
however the outcome of all discussions
and negotiations between officers of the
council and gladman during the course of
the planning application are outlined in
the three separate planning committee
reports all of which are available
online for viewing
thank you very much indeed leader
council ashby
well
councillors officers members of the
public that concludes this question and
answer session thank you to everyone in
attendance and those who have watched
from home
good night